le web 3.0 les objets connectés
on nous parle d'une grande révolution en
marche les objets du quotidien
les tables et chaises notre télé le
réfrigérateur ventre vont être relié à
l'internet les objets pardon on est
relié à l'internet
on va pouvoir raconter l'histoire d'une
d'un réfrigérateur qui sera que vous
devez acheter de la bière parce que
votre agenda lui aura dit que votre ami
d'enfance allait passer samedi prochain
on pourra raconter l'histoire de votre
réfrigérateur de votre agenda qui aura
dit à votre télévision de vous envoyer
de la publicité pendant toute la semaine
pour vous faire acheter des chips au
paprika
vous pourrez sûrement les commander en
ligne vous pourrez même les télécharger
si si les grandes équipes qui
travaillent aujourd'hui sur ses projets
avancent bien dans les grands
laboratoires américains
les équipes travaillent aujourd'hui à
construire ces technologies pour monde
pour rendre ce monde réel les
ordinateurs sont reliés entre eux les
bases de données sont reliées entre
elles des algorithmes puissant analyse
les données et font les recoupements qui
permettent aux fournisseurs de vendre
des poudres produit le bon produit à la
bonne personne au bon moment je suis
vigilant waro docteur en psychologie
cognitive spécialisée en intelligence
artificielle
j'ai travaillé dans le cadre de ma thèse
sur ces hasards ses algorithmes qui vous
fournissent automatiquement du contenu
et qui vous permettent de vous afin de
vous faire lire plus de vidéos en ligne
ou de pardon de vous faire consommer
plus de vidéos en ligne ou vous faire
lire plus d'articles la société dans
laquelle on vit aujourd'hui je cherche à
nous fournir plus de cours pardon
cherche à nous fournir le bon produit à
la bonne personne au bon moment mais
cela représente une contrepartie au
niveau technologique
il faut réussir à construire les
technologies qui permettent de capter le
maximum d'informations sur chaque
individu à chaque instant le maximum
d'informations à chaque individu à
chaque instant et c'est là que le
système peut devenir invasif en 2002 aux
etats-unis la chaîne de magasins target
envoie une publicité à une adolescente
de 16 ans pour lui proposer des
promotions sur des articles pour femmes
enceintes
le père de la jeune fille ouvre la boîte
aux lettres tombe sur cette publicité
furieux il va contacter le responsable
du magasin target souhaitons inciter sa
fille de 16 ans à tomber enceinte
le responsable du magasin à s'excuse et
un peu inquiet rappelle le père quinze
jours plus tard à ce moment là c'est le
père qui s'excuse auprès du responsable
du magasin il aa pris entre temps que sa
fille était effectivement enceinte
que s'est il passé target avait lancé un
programme de profilage des utilisateurs
spécialement dédié à la détection des
femmes enceintes dès le troisième ou le
quatrième mois à partir de l'analyse des
achats que faisait les clientes n'ont
pas d'achat spécifiquement liée au fait
d'être enceinte comme les pilules ou des
tests de grossesse mais plutôt la
détection d'un changement de taille dans
les vêtements de l'achat de certaines
crèmes à un moment donné dans un ordre
donné la société dans laquelle nous
vivons est une société de la captation
des données des utilisateurs
le bon produit à la bonne personne au
bon moment et les technologies qui capte
le maximum d'informations sur chaque
individu à chaque instant dit comme cela
on quitte l'univers du centre commercial
avec musique d'ambiance pour se
rapprocher du monde carcéral et de la
surveillance
le monde de la surveillance au xviiie
siècle
jeremy bentham décrit un modèle de
prison qui permet à aux gardiens de
surveiller chaque prisonnier à chaque
instant sans qu'un pied d'un prisonnier
puisse savoir si les surveiller à un
moment donné ce style de prison
s'appelle un panoptique vous en voyez
ici un exemple cubain depuis les
révélations edouard snowden sur la
captation des communications de
l'ensemble des utilisateurs au niveau
mondial par la nsa via les services du
web
de nombreuses voix se sont élevées pour
des signaler le danger que cela pouvait
représenter pour la liberté d'expression
la liberté d'opinion et la démocratie
elle-même le monde digital dans lequel
nous vivons s'inspire du panoptique et
le panoptique n'est pas qu'une menace
pour notre libre arbitre politique je
suis psychologue et il me semble que
l'aspect psychologique du problème est
sous-estimée avant les révélations des
douars snowden mark zuckerberg le
fondateur de facebook faisait la
déclaration publique pour prétendez que
la notion de vie privée était venue
devenu une notion obsolète en faisant
une telle déclaration mark zuckerberg ne
fait pas seulement la promotion du
panoptique comme idéal de société
merci marc il fait surtout il est non
surtout une contre vérité psychologique
la vie privée à avoir en psychologie
avec le concept d'intimité qui lui même
est un est une composante essentielle de
la combe la construction d'un individu
se construire c'est construire une
relation de soin et du monde et
construire une relation
il construit une représentation de la
relation entre soi et le monde
l'intimité se positionne dans cette
relation bâtie mythe est une est à
géométrie variable ce qui est intime
pour moi n'est peut-être pas intime pour
quelqu'un d'autre
ce que je considère comme pouvant être
partagés dans un contexte familial ou
amicale peut me paraît trop intime pour
être partagée dans un contexte
professionnel
quand bien même la notion d'intimité et
relative en fonction de l'individu des
époques des lieux c'est une elle existe
en tant que réalité psychologique elle
ne peut pas être comparée à un effet de
mode qui pourrait devenir obsolète
ceux qui construisent la société du
panoptique et de la négation de
l'intimité veulent nous faire croire que
les individus qui se meuvent dans cet
espace sont satisfaits il leur faut pour
cela imaginer des individus qui ne sont
pas comme vous et moi et qui n'ont pas
d'intimité mais il est possible de
construire un monde différent basé sur
des technologies différentes qui
respecte l'humain dans toutes ses
dimensions dans sa dimension publique
lorsqu'ils souhaitent échanger avec le
plus grand nombre comme je le fais
aujourd'hui est dans une dimension plus
intimes
lorsqu'il souhaite partager avec
certaines personnes sur certains sujets
le web deviendrait plus humain s'il
était capable de respecter notre
intimité le web tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui fonctionner comme si chaque
utilisateur n'est changé que des
informations publiques
nous avons créé avec didier waro et
fanilo harivelo un logiciel qui respecte
les principes d'intimité et qui
contribue à intégrer cette notion au web
le logiciel s'appelle placide place six
places 6 permet de partager des fichiers
de partager des messages d'avoir des de
partager des appels vidéo et
l'utilisateur peut être certain que ses
appels
ces contenus ne sont ne sont échangées
qu'avec la personne avec qui il échange
à aucun moment en utilisant pelé six en
tant que fournisseur du système ou
créatures du système nous n'avons accès
aux informations qui sont échangées
blaye 6 ne traite pas le problème de la
confidentialité par les conditions
d'utilisation en dix ans nous avons
collecté toutes vos données mais vous
pouvez nous faire confiance comme nous
l'avons vu le bon produit à la bonne
personne au bon moment repose sur des
technologies qui capte le maximum de
données sur chaque individu à chaque
instant le problème de la vie privée ne
peut pas être résolu sur une simple
déclaration
il doit être le problème est posé d'un
point de vue technologique et la réponse
doit être apportée
d'un point de vue technologique place il
utilise du code qui est open source
ça permettra aux développeurs qui
souhaitent vérifier que le logiciel
réalise bien le travail de chiffrement
et de commandes de sécurisation des
informations de vérifier que le logiciel
ne trahis pas les utilisateurs pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'internet les 3 millions les trois
milliards pardon d'utilisateurs ont le
choix de protéger leur vie privée avant
plei 6 ce choix était restreint aux
informaticiens et aux personnes un petit
peu avertis lorsqu'un utilisateur utile
utile lorsqu'un utilisateur 'utility'
utilise plus pardon lorsqu'un
utilisateur utilise playes 6
il utilise le même niveau de chiffrement
le même niveau de sécurité que edward
snowden lorsqu'il a fait les révélations
de l'année ça alors un choix se pose à
nous maintenant précisent existe le
choix qui se posent à nous c'est voulons
nous être ceux qui quittent le
panoptique voulons nous être ceux qui
partent vers un avenir plus éclairée du
web
nous avons déjà depuis le mois de
septembre 2000 utilisateurs qui
utilisent précise et dont les données
sont entièrement chiffrée et qui peuvent
accéder à des espaces intimes si vous
souhaitez
si vous souhaitez contribuer à nous
éloigner du panoptique si vous souhaitez
contribuer à éclairer l'avenir du web à
nous rejoindre dans play civ je vous
demande de mettre un peu de lumière dans
cette salle de prendre votre téléphone
de quitter le panoptique de nous
rejoindre sur play 6 encore je vois des
téléphones bravo chacun peut éclairer le
monde dans lequel il vit
lorsque vous allez rentrer chez vous
tout à l'heure vous allez recevoir un
e-mail qui vous propose de télécharger
place 6 prenez vos téléphones éclairer
le monde dans lequel vous vivez vous
pouvez utiliser pla i 6 pour envoyer les
photos que vous des photos de famille
que vous n'avez jamais partager sur le
web vous pouvez utiliser placide pour
appeler vos proches
à l'autre bout du monde il est possible
d'éclairer l'avenir du web
je vous remercie
merci